RYAN BOYD: Hello everyone.
My name is Ryan Boyd and I'm a
Developer Advocate at Google
focused on Google Apps and
the Apps Marketplace.
But today, we're actually here
to talk about OpenID and OAuth
and how they work for identity
and data access.
If you have any questions
throughout the talk, you can
save them for the end.
We will have a Q&A period.
Of course, I'll also be around
the rest of the conference in
between the sandbox and office
hours and things like that.
And you can reach me online
via my Twiiter profile,
ryguyrg and my Google profile
is linked there as well.
And lastly, there's a feedback
link at the top right, which
the box gets slightly cut
off on the screen.
But you can record your feedback
there and that will
be helpful for me to improve
the talk for the future.
All right, so what are we
here to talk about?
There's a number of items
on our agenda.
But basically it breaks down
to talking about OpenID and
talking about OAuth.
And then talking about a couple
of different scenarios
for each of those, including
how to handle mobile
authentication as well how to
handle OAuth for businesses
and organizations.
And then we're going to talk a
little bit about the future of
these technologies, and the
future is going to come quite
quickly in this case.
All right, terminology.
Terminology is really key to
understanding these topics.
I hope I don't bore you too much
by introducing new terms
and describing them a couple
different ways.
But that's what I'm
going to be doing.
With each term I'm going to try
to talk about them in a
real world use case, and then
try to talk about them in an
online use case.
And hopefully between those two,
you can get them because
it'll really help
understanding.
So the first term we're going
to talk about today is
authentication.
Authentication is about
verifying the identity of a
user, knowing that the user
is who they say they are.
In the case of Colonel Tom
visiting a top-secret military
establishment, his identity
is verified using
a scan of his eye.
Then after his identity is
verified by the folks at the
military base, they then need
to decide what Colonel Tom
should have access to.
In particular, what rooms on the
military base Colonel Tom
should be able to go into.
And that's what authorization is
all about, making sure that
someone has the right access and
only the right access when
they go to access
some resources.
So in the online world,
let's meet Bob.
Everyone say hi to Bob.
Hi, Bob.
All right, Bob, is an
Administrative Assistant at
Acme Corporation.
And Bob uses his computer
every single day.
And the first thing Bob does
when he goes to his
compute is log in.
He types in a username
and a password.
That gets sent off to the server
and the server says,
hey, is this the correct
password for this username?
And if so, the user is
considered authenticated.
The server thinks that if this
person provided the right
password for this account,
then it must in
fact, be that person.
Not always true as you guys
know, but that's the basics of
authentication as it works
in most websites.
But after the user's
authenticated, we need to
figure out what access the user
should have. So in the
case of this Acme Corporation,
we have Bob being able to
access his own mail, but not
being able to access the mail
of the other people in
the organization.
So Bob is authenticated to his
Acme Corp account and has
authorized access
to his mailbox.
Now, to put these in context
for the presentation, for
authentication we're going
to be primarily
talking about OpenID.
And when authenticating a user
using OpenID when they're
visiting a website.
And then for OAuth we're
primarily talking about
getting authorized access to a
user's data, kind of delegated
access to a user's data that
is stored elsewhere.
In this case, at Google.
So authenticating users via
OpenID, or authentication of
users via OpenID.
That's what I get for adding
slides at the last minute.
OpenID terminology.
So let's get into some
terms and first talk
about identity providers.
The most common identity
provider that you're probably
familiar with is the Department
of Motor Vehicles.
When you go there you prove
your identity to them, and
they issue you a driver's
license.
And that driver's license
says, hey, this is Tom.
This is Tom's birthdate and
some other information.
Now if you take that driver's
license, walk to your car, and
speed out of the parking lot,
and get pulled over by a cop,
that cop is what's called
a relying party.
That cop is relying upon the
assertion of your identity by
the identity provider in order
to write you a ticket.
So he looks at the driver's
license and if the picture
matches he says, this is Tom.
This is his birthdate.
This is his address,
et cetera.
And he issues you the ticket.
Now how does this work
in the online world?
Let's give you an example of
federated identity in the
online world and we'll
bring Bob back.
So Bob is an Administrative
Assistant,
but he's often traveling.
He's on the road, rushing to
catch his next plane, and he
doesn't always remember
where he's going next.
So he stores his itineraries in
a travel planning service
called TripIt.
TripIt is basically a place you
can store your itineraries
and share them with your
friends and colleagues.
And he goes to TripIt, but he
doesn't want to have to create
another account.
He doesn't want to have to
create another password.
So he goes to TripIt and he
says, TripIt, I want to use my
Google account to log in.
And TripIt says, OK, Google,
who is this guy?
And Google returns and says,
hey, TripIt, this is Bob.
So in this case, we have Bob as
the end user, TripIt as the
relying party, and Google as
the identity provider.
And we have success, the user is
authenticated to his TripIt
account using his
Google identity.
And most importantly, never
actually had to have a
password on TripIt.
Because Google is asserting
his identity to TripIt, he
only necessarily had to have
a password at Google.
So why do we care
about OpenID?
We care about OpenID for a
number of different reasons.
I'm going to go through
several of them here.
But basically, users can log
in to all sites using their
existing accounts.
They don't have to create a new
account and new identities
to log into websites.
All right, so this is the quote
that's on the front page
of openid.net, or was at
the time that I looked.
"OpenID is a safe, faster, and
easier way to log in to
websites."
We're going to go through
each of these points.
We're going to start with
faster and easier
and get back to safe.
But I truly believe in this.
So faster and easier.
Let's look at a traditional
signup process.
So traditional signup process--
this is a fictitious
app called SaaSy Payroll.
Just a screen shot here.
But this is a typical signup
process where you fill out
your first name, last name,
e-mail address, provide a
password, double enter
that password.
And if you're like me, you often
typo that password when
you double enter it.
So this takes a little
bit of time.
But you fill out this form,
and then you get an e-mail
sent to you that confirms that
you have that e-mail address.
And this whole process took
about 50 keystrokes and 3
mouse click.
Of course, if you have a more
complicated password, it may
have taken you even more.
But this is a really
bad process.
This process make babies cry.
And why are babies crying?
Babies are crying because even
babies know that you can offer
a better user experience for
signing up for a website.
Even babies know or should
know about OpenID.
And how you can offer
an improved user
experience with OpenID.
So let's take a look at that
same sort of process and see
how that works in OpenID.
This is the log in box
at one time on a
website called Tungle.
And they're presenting a variety
of different options
for you to log in using an
existing account that you
already have. These are a
variety of different identity
providers and this is often
referred to as something like
the OpenID NASCAR.
That was a term someone else
came up with, but it's a good
way to describe it.
It's basically a bunch
of different logos.
And in here you can choose from
one of the major identity
providers to log in with.
It doesn't actually provide the
option for you to log in
with your own identity on your
own identity provider if
you're a real geek.
And that's unfortunate for
many people, but it is
actually what you see
most often because
it's easier for users.
So they see this, and if you
have a Google account, you'd
click on the Google button.
You're already logged in to your
Google account so you get
prompted, hey, would you like
to allow or deny access to
your Google account?
And you say, hey, I'm going
to allow access.
And then you're signed
into the website.
It was really that simple.
This whole process was 0
keystrokes and 2 mouse clicks.
This is making puppies happy.
Now would you rather make puppy
happy than babies cry?
Hopefully everyone.
All right.
This is what it's all about.
It's basically making your users
happier and not making
your babies cry.
So now let's talk about safer.
We've talked about faster and
easier, how is it safer?
It's safer for a number
of different reasons.
You have one username
and password.
You don't have to create
username and passwords for
every different site
you visit.
You have one.
Because you only have one that
password can be ultra- secure.
It can be something that you
really are going to remember
and you're going to remember
every single time that you go
to enter it.
My typical password is many
times the length of the eight
character limitation that
sites give you.
It always frustrates me when
I'm limited at eight
characters because I want to
have an ultra-secure password.
And I can have an ultra-secure
password because there's only
a few places I actually
provide that password.
The password is only provided
to the identity provider.
Only the identity provider
ever sees that password.
All these other sites, all the
other relying parties never
see a password from you.
This makes it definitely much
safer because most users--
actually, how many of you reuse
the same password on
multiple sites?
See.
It's very helpful to have that
one password provided to the
identity provider and only
the identity provider.
Now, in addition to having a
password, you can also have
what's called two factor auth
and other protections.
How many of you are familiar
with two factor auth?
All right, so I don't have to
explain that to most of you.
For those of you that don't
understand it, basically the
idea is security is
done in layers.
And one of those layers
is something
you know, your password.
Another layer might be something
that you are, which
is like the eye scan
of Colonel Tom.
But the last layer might be
something that you have.
When I go to log into my typical
identity provider, I'm
actually prompted to not enter
the password and only the
password, but asked
to enter in a
one-time password as well.
The way Google has implemented
it mostly for external
purposes is you get an SMS
message or you get a
notification on your mobile
device and it proves that you
have something in your
possession in addition to
knowing the password.
It makes it quite easy and also,
quite secure because
only if you have that in your
possession and know the
password are you able
to log into sites.
All right, so safe,
faster, easier.
Safer, user only provides
their one ultra-secure
password to their identity
provider.
And that ultra-secure password
could be backed up with
something like two
factor auth.
The user is often already logged
in to their identity
provider, so it's super fast
as you saw earlier.
And the user doesn't need
to create the other
username and password.
Now, this is how it's
safer, faster, and
easier for your users.
The next question though is,
how is it easier for you as
developers?
And we're going to talk a little
bit about becoming an
OpenID relying party
and how this makes
things easier for you.
Or doesn't in some cases.
But at least it makes it
easier for your users.
All right, so I'm going
to assert that
OpenID is easy to implement.
Now, how many of you would
disagree with me?
How many of you have looked
at this at all?
All right, good.
It's easy to implement, but
it's not easy enough.
It's not easy enough because
there are a huge number of
edge cases.
Now I've worked with probably
a couple hundred OpenID
replying parties over the last
couple of years on the Google
Apps Marketplace and these edge
cases are things that a
lot of people don't deal
with to start out with.
These edge cases are things that
you can get by without
implementing it first. You can
implement the basics of OpenID
using OpenID libraries.
There are a variety of different
libraries and
different languages that you
can use and get by without
implementing these edge cases.
But if you do that, then your
customer support folks get the
burden of the problem.
And that's because there are
edge cases such as an existing
user wants to switch to using
OpenID, or an OpenID user
wants to switch back to
using a password.
A user changes their e-mail
address, what do you do?
And there's a link at the bottom
here where those are
documented.
But a variety of different edge
cases that most OpenID
relying parties don't actually
implement, and then their
customer support people
get angry.
And the cost of them
implementing OpenID is
actually more than the
benefit that they're
achieving from it.
So you kind of have to implement
these edge cases,
and everyone will eventually
deal with them.
But let's make it easier.
Let's make it easier to
implement OpenID.
Let's make it easier to become
a relying party.
And we're going to do that by
introducing to you the Google
Identity Toolkit.
Now, what you're seeing
here probably
doesn't what that exciting.
You just see a username
and password.
But you might see the second
tab over here that says
connect with any account.
And that connect with any
account tab has a couple of
different options.
Has Gmail, Yahoo, AOL, and
Hotmail is actually now on the
official list. And this allows
you to log in using your
existing identity, but with
less pain as developers.
And it has less pain because we
provide a mixture of three
components here: JavaScript UI
widgets, client libraries, and
code on Google's servers to
actually make this process a
lot easier for you
as developers.
And it's easier for you, but
it's also more prescriptive.
Basically we provide
interfaces for you to implement.
And if you implement those
interfaces, we actually are
dealing with a lot of the
different edge cases that we
talked about earlier.
Now this project is just kind
of in testing currently.
I will have at the end of the
presentation, some e-mail
address and that sort of thing
that you can reach out to to
get to test this project.
But it should be
fully out soon.
If you search for it right now
on the web I think you
probably come to a website about
it, but again, more at
the end of the presentation
in the resources section.
Now the Google Identity Toolkit
supports two different
flavors of OpenID.
It supports using OpenID only
for signup, so that when users
go to signup for your
application, you can sign them
up using their existing
identities.
And you get some special
information by that.
You get their name, you got
their e-mail address.
It basically prevents the user
from having to enter in some
of the common information.
And then you can authenticate
the users via password after
you sign them up.
Now, I personally don't like
this as you can imagine.
I'd much rather you implement an
OpenID for signup and also
for your day-to-day login.
However, many websites aren't
comfortable with that, so we
do offer both of these options
in the Google Identity Toolkit
to be as flexible as possible.
And then there are a variety
of different identity
providers that you can use, and
I believe it's an option
when you're configuring it.
You can choose which of these
different identity
providers to accept.
All right, so now that we talked
about making it easier
for you to implement OpenID
using the Google Identity
Toolkit, let's show you what
it actually looks like.
There's a quick video here.
I say connect with any account,
I click on Gmail.
A little pop-up occurs.
I agree to pass on
that information.
I say allow.
And again, my name and
e-mail address.
And then it's asking me for some
additional information in
one of these example widgets.
So the Google Identity Toolkit
makes it easier for you, as a
web application developer,
to implement OpenID.
With working with all these
different partners I have one
question that keeps
on coming up.
And that question is, when
users are logging into my
website with OpenID, they
don't have a password.
And when they don't have a
password, how can they use my
mobile applications?
So they have mobile
applications, native mobile
applications, that exist on
iPhones and Androids and
BlackBerrys.
These native mobile apps
typically have a username and
password field.
And they don't need to know
how to authenticate their
users that are authenticated
to their website
with just an OpenID.
And the problem here is that
they have code that may have
been written by a contractor
or written by someone who's
moved on to another project,
it's native code sitting on
their devices.
So how do they deal with that?
One option is allow the users
to create a password.
Now this isn't my favorite
option as you might imagine.
But it's the easiest option
for developers.
So all of these different
options are basically on the
scale of is it easier
for developers or is
it easier for users?
Somewhere along the that scale,
these options are fitting.
This is kind of an
extreme end.
It's really easy for developers
because they just
need to add something in their
settings panel that allows the
user to create a password.
Concur is an application on
the Apps Marketplace and
they've done exactly that.
If you go to their settings
panel, you can choose to
create a password and that
password's used to
authenticate you in
the mobile device.
But let's get a little
bit better.
Let's not allow the users to
come up with a password and
reuse the password that they
might have already used on
many others sites.
Let's generate a password that's
reasonably complex and
give it to them.
This is actually a screen shot
from one of the Google
interfaces that if you're using
the two factor auth you
have the ability to do this.
You have the ability to go in
and say, I want to create a
password for this particular
mobile app, or this particular
website, or what have you.
And it gives you a password.
You only see that
password once.
It's kind of assumed that that
mobile application is
remembering your identity.
Most mobile applications, once
you log into them, they assume
that you're mobile phone is
fairly secure and don't make
you log in on a regular basis.
So this works OK for that.
But the user still needs to go
and figure out where this is
and get that password,
and enter it.
So, OpenID.
Did you all guess that that's
what I was going to talk about
here as my favorite
way hopefully?
OpenID is really my favorite
way to authenticate mobile
devices and native mobile
applications.
Now OpenID wasn't designed
for this.
I'm not going to go out
and say, this was the
whole point of OpenID.
OpenID's really about
websites.
But OpenID can work on native
applications and native mobile
applications in particular.
And so we're going to talk
about how that's done.
So this is the TripIt
application on an Android.
TripIt is the travel planning
service I mentioned earlier.
Basically, they native mobile
applications on several
different platforms. This is
their application on Android.
So you click on the signup to
TripIt or sign in to TripIt.
And basically, it pops up
a web page like this.
This is popping up in a new
browser window outside of the
application.
And when this pops up, you
actually first get a thing to
create a new account
for TripIt.
I skipped that screen.
This is about signing in.
And you see the link at the
bottom that says sign in with
your Google account?
You click and sign
in with Google.
And again, since you're already
logged into your
account on your mobile device,
you're prompted just to allow.
Now a little tip and trick for
those of you who go about
implementing this.
Some people will implement this
flow by using an embedded
web browser in the
application.
If you do that, that embedded
browser often has a different
cookie store, cookie jar, than
your main web browser.
So even if a user was logged
in in the main web browser,
they'll have to log in again.
That's why I much prefer the
flow of actually popping up
the native browser on the device
and not trying to do an
embedded web view.
So I can just here allow,
click allow.
And I'm in to TripIt.
It's really that simple.
So it's a four-step process.
One, two, three, four
for the user.
Like I said, OpenID's not
designed for the, so it can be
a little bit tricky
for the developer.
But for the user, it's
really simple.
Some people still are concerned
about this pop-up
web browser, but I would much
rather have the UI of having a
web browser pop up than having
to enter my password on a
mobile device with that
little thumb keyboard.
This is how you can deal with
authentication on mobile devices.
If you have some questions
about how to deal with
authorization, how to get access
to a user's calendar or
contacts or something like that
on a mobile device, there
was actually a session
yesterday, which you can catch
hopefully tomorrow on YouTube.
The session was called Client
Login Hashfail.
And that session did go into a
little bit more detail about
how to deal with using OAuth
from mobile devices.
The other thing that they talked
about in that session
is a little bit more of the
future of how this will work
and how we can make it easier
for you as developers by
essentially having a native
application on the device,
which you, as developers, can
talk to to get the user's
identity and access to their
data rather than having to go
through the OpenID dance.
So check out that session.
Look for things happening
in the future there.
But that's a really good
transition into getting
authorized data access
via OAuth.
Now OAuth is an open protocol.
OAuth is an open protocol just
like OpenID, but its point is
to get delegated and
authorized access
from users to data.
So you might ask why I
care or why you care.
You care because there are a
bunch of different APIs out
there that you can use to
get access to with this
technology.
There are 35 plus APIs
at Google that are
authorized via OAuth.
And these 35 plus APIs do a
variety of different things.
And not only are there 35 plus
APIs at Google, but there are
hundreds and hundreds of APIs
around the web that our
authorized using OAuth.
But really, what matters is what
those APIs provide your
application.
So those APIs at Google--
I'm going to give you a couple
examples about the type of
data that your app can
access using OAuth.
The first one is contacts.
Let's say you have a web
application and you want to
allow users to invite other
users, their friends and that
sort of thing, to your
application.
And those users are storing that
data in Google Contacts.
Well it's pretty simple for
you to use OAuth and get
access to their data and pool a
feed of the user's contacts
and allow them to send e-mails
to their friends inviting them
to your website.
Calendar.
I'm sorry, your application
manages events in some way,
and you want to allow the users
to add events to their
own calendars because they use
Google Calendar on a regular
basis and that's where they want
to store the history of
all their events and keep track
of them in one place.
You can use the Calendar API.
Picasa Web Albums, YouTube, some
other cases where if you
want to embed a user's photos
or get access to a user's
videos, you could do all that
by getting authorized access
with OAuth.
And then the rest of it is
kind of read-only feeds.
Most of these are based off
Atom Publishing Protocol.
So once you get authorized
access with OAuth, you're
reading in XML or Atom-based
feed using a
standard rest scenario.
So fairly simple, but why do you
need to learn this really
fancy protocol in order to get
access to users' data?
Why don't you just ask them
for their password?
All right, you shouldn't ask
them for their password.
But how many of you have seen
websites that look like this?
Tell us your Gmail account, we
promise we won't tell anyone
your password.
You guys all seen this?
Well it really irritates me
every time I see it because I
know there's a better way and
the babies are out there
crying because they know
there's a better way.
You can access a user's data
with their password.
That is correct.
Right now, our APIs do allow
you to take the user's
username and password and get
access to their data.
But this is really bad because
the user is granting access to
their entire account
at that point.
They're not just granting access
to the one API or two
APIs that your application
needs access to.
They're granting access to
everything in their Google
account, the whole world.
You do not want that as a user
and you don't want to ask your
users to do that
as a developer.
Because the smart users will
stand back and say, no, no.
I really don't want
to do that.
And the dumb users will just
give you their password and
you'll have a database
full of passwords.
And that's just a really
bad thing.
So don't put yourself in that
risk scenario as a user or as
a developer.
All right, so some terminology
with OAuth.
We have a protected resource.
This is the resource on
a server that requires
authorization to access.
We have the resource owner,
the person that owns the
protected resource and
approves access.
And then we have the server.
The server is holding the
protected resource and
deciding whether or not it
should grant access.
And then the client.
Again, we're going to use this
SaaSy Payroll example as a web
application, which needs access
to data that's stored
on the server.
All right, so which flavor
of OAuth do you use?
There's plenty of different
flavors at Google
and at other providers.
And what flavor of OAuth
you use depends on
who owns the data.
You can have individual
ownership of data where every
user gets to decide, this is
my data, I'm going to grant
this application access
to my data.
And that user can make
that decision.
But then you can also have
company owned resources.
So think of something like,
you're in a very large company
and that company has calendars,
for instance.
You have your corporate
calendar.
You might have some confidential
stuff on your
corporate calendar.
Your company does not trust
you to be the one deciding
whether a third party app can
grant access or can get access
to the calendar.
So you have these IT guardians
that sit and make those
decisions, evaluate the security
of apps, and that
sort of thing.
So we're going to go through
these two scenarios and the
different flavors of OAuth that
are used in these two
different flavors.
So we're going to start off by
the individual grant case,
where the individual
owns the resource.
And I'm going to be somewhat
lazy here and use the
application SaaSy Payroll
to demonstrate this.
And why I say somewhat lazy is
because this is really an
individual use case that
we're talking about.
So let's imagine that we're at a
very small company of just a
couple of employee, there's no
IT guardians to protect us.
But we have this payroll
application and we want to
allow this payroll application
to add our pay dates onto our
Google Calendar.
Again, we keep track of all
of our dates in our Google
Calendar in one place and
we want to know when our
payroll's coming up without
having to log in to the
payroll app.
So the payroll application
could look
something like this.
They give you your paycheck and
then at the bottom they
have a link that allows
you to add your pay
dates to your calendar.
This pops up a screen that
looks like this.
This is the OAuth 2 flow.
And this screen basically says,
hey, this SaaSy Payroll
application would like to manage
your calendar, view and
manage the events on
your calendar.
The user hits allow access and
all of a sudden, the app,
after a little redirect dance,
can actually put the pay dates
on your Google Calendar.
So now you don't have to log
into Payroll each time you
want to see when you get paid.
Awesome.
Now, let's talk about this in a
little more detail and what
the technical flow is.
And we're going to start off by
talking about this in the
aspect of a developer going
to build an app
for the first time.
The developer has to actually
register their application and
get a client ID client
secret from Google.
And they go to a screen that
looks like this; Google says,
here's your client ID
and client secret.
And then the developer puts
that in their production
infrastructure somewhere in a
secure fashion, so that when
they make future requests
and the user visits the
application, they have
access to that data.
So now the user came to that web
page and said, I went to
add my payroll dates to
my Google Calendar.
And the web developer
does a few things in
their code, of course.
The application will redirect
the user over to Google and
includes a client ID, includes
a redirect URI, which is the
URI to redirect the
user back to after
they're done this process.
And includes a scope.
The scope is basically what APIs
that this application is
trying to get access to.
At Google these scopes are often
in the form of URLs.
They don't have to be.
And you can actually include
multiple scopes at once.
So we just asked for Calendar
here, but you could ask for
Calendar and Contacts and
YouTube and that sort of thing
all at one try.
So the application redirects
user to Google with that
information.
There's luckily no
signatures or
anything like that involved.
It's just a clear
URL that you're
redirecting the user to.
And then Google redirects the
user back to the application,
the redirect URI that
was specified.
And includes a code
in that URL.
And the URL looks something
like this.
It's a URL on the application,
and then we have a code that
says authorization code.
And then the application
performs a post to Google.
And in that post, it basically
includes it client ID and
client secret, and also
includes that code.
When it does this, Google looks
up and responds to that
request by giving the
application two main things.
The first is its access token.
This is the token that
will be used to make
requests to the API.
And we're going to see how
that works shortly.
And then the second main thing
is this refresh token.
So the access token actually
expires once every 3,920
seconds in this example.
That can be a variable
number of course.
And when that access token
expires, you need to go off
and get another access token.
And you can do that using
the refresh token.
And this refresh token is
actually with Google in our
current implementation, valid
indefinitely until the user
revokes it.
So either before or after the
token expires, you can use
that refresh token
to renew access.
And we're going to see how that
works here in a second.
But first, let's take that
access token and actually make
a call to the API.
We're going to make that call
to the API specifying that
access token in one
of two ways.
You can specify it as a query
parameter in your request. So
just in the URL you can say,
the OAuth token is this.
Or you can specify
as a header.
If you guys are going off and
making the decision, well,
which one should I use?
Please use the header in
most circumstances.
I want you to use the header
because the header is often
not logged in proxy server logs
or in your web server
logs, or things like that.
Although these tokens are just
valid for 3,920 seconds, it's
still helpful for you to keep
that data out of the logs and
will make your app a little
bit more secure.
But that being said, the query
parameter is also really
useful for debugging and the
query parameter is useful if
you're writing JavaScript
applications.
With this whole OAuth 2 flow,
you can write JavaScript
applications pretty much
entirely within your browser
and not have to have much
server side code.
So that's helpful.
We've made a call to
the protected API.
We've waited a period of time.
There are 3,920 seconds.
And I think I skipped
something here.
And we need to refresh
the access token.
You can refresh that access
token, like I said, before or
after the token has expired.
So some applications might want
to say, I'm using this
access a lot.
The user's active in
their session.
And it's been 3,800 seconds.
Let me go off and refresh
the access
token behind the scenes.
Or you might want to say, we're
just going to wait until
Google returns an error.
And after Google returns an
error, we're going to try to
refresh this.
You can do either one.
Basically, you're specifying the
client ID, client secret,
and the refresh token.
And Google will return an
access token to you.
Pretty simple.
So the whole flow works
something like this.
The developer registers the
application at Google.
The user visits the
application.
The application asked the user
to authorize access at data--
or access data at Google.
The Google clicks that allow
button and says, I'm going to
grant access to this
application.
Google returns to the
application with the code.
Then the application actually
requests an update--
a access token from that code.
And Google returns both
that access token
and the refresh token.
And again, the refresh token
is valid indefinitely, even
though the access token's
expiring.
Then the application can
actually access Google
Calendar by specifying that
access token in either the URL
or the query parameter.
Google returns or updates
protected data.
Sometime later, you have to go
through this renewal process
by passing in the refresh token
and getting back a new
access token.
So this is a whole
OAuth 2 flow.
I did not mention the word
signatures at all.
For those of you who have dealt
with OAuth one, that's
kind of one of the bigger
pain points of OAuth 1.
But the next case that I'm going
to introduce to you is
going to be the business
ownership of data.
And with the business ownership
of data, we are
going to be using a flavor of
OAuth 1, which has signatures.
But hopefully, eventually that's
going to go away in
favor of OAuth 2 based
protocols.
So in the business scenario
this is going to be the
company owning the resource.
There's this team of IT
guardians who are protecting
access to the data owned by a
company, and they want to
grant access.
And there's two different ways
that the company can grant
access to data.
And in these examples, the way
that we deal with companies at
Google is via Google Apps.
So these two examples are
going to be based off of
Google Apps.
And the first one is in the
Google Apps Control Panel.
A company can grant an
application access to a
particular API or scope as we
talked about earlier, via the
Google Apps Control Panel by
specifying the name of their
client and consumer key and
specifying the scope of data
that it needs access to,
or multiple scopes.
So this would basically be
saying, SaaSy Payroll can have
access to Google Calendar.
And once they authorize that
in the Business Edition or
Education Edition of Google
Apps, once that's authorized
that application now has access
to that API for every
user within the organization.
The other way is via the Google
Apps Marketplace.
So an application that's
distributed on the Google Apps
Marketplace can say, I need
access to Google Calendar in
order for my application
to work.
And when the IT administrator
installs that application from
the Apps Marketplace, they can
grant access to that data in
that one step during the
install process.
It's a very simple flow.
Makes it a lot easier than
copying and pasting scopes and
that sort of thing.
So after they do that because
the application has access to
every user within the
organization--
their Calendar, their
Contacts, and
that sort of thing--
then SaaSy Payroll could not
only update my calendar, but
can also update the calendar
of everyone else within the
organization with their payroll
dates without those
users ever having to
actively log in.
So remember, the administrator
gave them permission to do
this, and then they can go off
in the background and update
all these different calendars.
And I may never actually have to
see the payroll application
because I know when I'm
going to get paid.
So let's go through what
this looks like
from a technical basis.
There's the first step here.
It actually is split into two,
depending on whether you're an
Apps Marketplace application or
whether you're just trying
to get access in the
Control Panel.
The one I'm showing here is the
screen of where you need
to go register as a developer
if you just want the
administrators to grant
access in the Google
Apps Control Panel.
This is the OAuth 1 standard
registration page linked to
from our documentation,
which I'll refer to at
the end of the talk.
But this standard authorization
page, or
registration page, will give
you this OAuth consumer key
and secret.
If you're an Apps Marketplace
app, it's a very similar
process in that you go and
register your application, but
Google actually gives you the
consumer key and consumer
secret at the time that
you register.
So you've registered, the
administrator grants access in
one of those two different ways
that we talked about.
And then you start
to make requests.
And you make requests
by including an
authorization header.
So that's the part that's kind
of similar to before.
There's an authorization header
in your HTTP request.
It references the key for
the application and also
references a couple other
bits of data.
If you're using OAuth 1, I would
definitely recommend you
use some library that
implements OAuth 1.
Google has a variety of
libraries for it.
OAuth 2, the stuff that we
talked about before because
there's no signatures, that sort
of thing, you're actually
able to pretty easily
write your own code
that handles that.
I did that kind of in less than
an hour accessing several
different APIs using OAuth 2.
That's fine.
But with OAuth 1, you will
want some sort of library
because you need to generate
these cryptographic
signatures.
And these cryptographic
signatures are based off of a
[INAUDIBLE],
a time stamp, your consumer
secret, and
that sort of thing.
But let's assume you have this
library generating this
authorization header for you,
and you're accessing the
Calendar API.
The other thing that you need
to do is specify on whose
behalf you're accessing
the Calendar API.
So if you remembered inside
the organization that we
talked about with SaaSy Payroll,
we had Ryan, Tim,
Scott, a variety of
different users.
For each user, you need to
specify their e-mail address
as the xoauth requestor to ID
when you're making the request
to the API.
And that's how you do it.
Fairly simple, as long as you
have that library backed up
and helping you out with that
authorization header.
So here's the general flow.
The developer registers
the application.
The admin visits the Google and
authorizes the application
in the Control Panel.
And then the application--
somehow or another I messed
up my transitions here.
But the application then
accesses Google Calendar by
specifying that xoauth
requester ID header.
xoauth requstor ID sorry,
as a query parameter.
And then an authorization
header with a signature.
And Google returns or updates
the protected data.
Then they can go through and
access that data for another
user by just specifying a
different xoauth requestor ID.
So we talked about a number
of different things.
We talked about general
terminology for authentication
and authorization.
Then we talked about OpenID
authentication, mobile
authentication, and how to use
OAuth in two different areas.
First, using OAuth and this is
OAuth 2, or 2.0, for accessing
individual users' data.
And then we talked about using
OAuth 1, the two-legged flow
for accessing data that's
authorized by businesses.
Now what's the future
look like?
The future is all
about having one
protocol for all use cases.
You want a single protocol to
handle both authentication and
authorization.
You're all probably thinking,
why do we have both this
OpenID and this OAuth thing?
Really, we can eliminate
one of them.
And we can eliminate one of them
because the process is
essentially the same.
If you look at this page, this
page was copied kind of from
the OAuth 2 flow for an
individual user granting
access to their calendar, and
I've modified it a little bit
to say, this application
would like access
to your Google identity.
And they'd like to view your
e-mail address and name.
So instead of granting the
application access to your
Calendar data, it's just
granting access to your
identity and that information.
So essentially it's using OAuth
2 to get access to your
identity and use OAuth 2 for
authentication in addition to
authorization.
Now there's certainly some
different guarantees between
the clients and servers going
on here about what needs to
happen when you're getting
access to a calendar versus
what needs to happen when
you're getting access to
someone's identity.
But the flow and what it
looks like to users
is mostly the same.
So this has actually been
proposed as a project called
OpenID Connect.
And I don't know exactly what
our timeline is as Google to
implement something like that.
But this is really where we
see the future going.
We see the future as the ability
to use OAuth to get
access not only to a user's
data, like their calendar or
their contacts.
But also to get access
to their identity.
So you, as developers, don't
need to deal with the
complicated issues
of signatures and
that sort of thing.
There will still be some things
for discovery when
we're talking about
authentication.
Basically figuring
out who a user's
authentication provider is.
But overall, this should make
it a lot easier for getting
access to a user's identity and
getting access to their
data by learning only
a single protocol.
So a variety of different
resources that you have here.
The Google Identity Toolkit,
which I talked about earlier,
is basically that toolkit to
make it a lot easier to do
OpenID authentication.
And there's someone's
e-mail address.
They were brave enough
to put that up there,
please don't spam them.
But if you are interested in
using the Google Identity
Toolkit and trying it out
on your website, contact
esachs@google.com and
he can hook you up.
And then there's some links
for various other
documentation.
Google has one main site for
all of our all auth docs.
And then there's also the
OAuth playground there.
It's using OAuth 1, so it's a
little bit different flow for
the individual case.
But it's a very helpful tool to
learn some of this and to
try out our various APIs.
And then, as I mentioned
earlier, there's a client
login fail session that
happened yesterday.
Catch up on that on YouTube.
And you can reach me via
Twitter at ryguyrg.
And of course, if you have any
feedback on this session,
please submit it in that
feedback link below.
Now it's time for Q&A.
Questions?
There are microphones.
Looks like someone's already
standing so, go for it.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
On the enterprise side, it looks
like it's pretty good.
You know, I have somebody else
making a decision for me.
But when I'm using Google
personally right now, I'm
trying to store information
on there.
Always worried about still
using open auth and
everything.
And that's because there's no
granular level of access.
If somebody has access to my
documents, there's everything.
It's just open.
My calendar, they got access
to all my calendars.
Is there a thought about
creating silos where the
interested party can only have
access to a certain calendar
or a certain folders
in a document?
That's one question.
Just kind of going back on it
also, I'd like to know when
they pull data from my calendar,
how often they do
that, and where do they
store the data?
So that I can be knowledgeable
of what they're doing with it.
Those two concerns there.
RYAN BOYD: So yeah, two
basic questions.
First was about more granular
level of access.
And yes, it's definitely
something that we're looking
at and we've implemented for a
couple newer APIs, the ability
to get access.
First of all, just kind of as
a read-only way versus a
read-write fashion.
But then we're also looking at
say, access to things like an
individual Google Doc, or
individual Google Calendar.
Definitely looking
at all that.
And the second was
on audit ability.
I agree with you.
That's all I'm going
to say on that.
But I agree with you and
it'd be nice to be
able to see that data.
AUDIENCE: On the OpenID part
of your presentation, how
would OpenID work if you have a
Google Apps account and your
Gmail account and your OpenId is
more on the Gmail side and
you are working on your
Google Apps account.
Cookie-wise, it's
going to be--
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, so Google
has a couple of
different types of accounts.
The primary type of account
that's always existed is kind
of the consumer account, regular
Gmail accounts that
you guys are used to.
The second type of account
is a Google Apps account.
And we've actually tried to
move these Google Apps
accounts recently into becoming
full regular consumer
accounts in addition
to having access to
the business services.
I actually don't know how
that works right now.
I actually login, I use
incognito window for my
consumer stuff and use
a regular window
for my business access.
But I think that the way that
that should access or should
work is really having
a choice.
Is having when you go to
OpenID basically being
prompted and say, which account
would you like to
authenticate with?
Depending on how the developer
has implemented OpenID, we do
have some hints on that in the
process they went through.
But yeah, it's definitely
something that the team's
aware of, and I was actually
talking with them two or three
weeks ago, with the engineers
that are implementing this.
And it's something we're aware
of and hopefully, we'll fix
soon for you, so you
don't have to use
that incognito window.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RYAN BOYD: Yep.
Let's alternate back
over to here.
AUDIENCE: First of all, thanks
for the great talk.
I'm wondering if you have
anything to say about the
potential privacy implications
of sort of telling Google
every website I login to
at exactly what time I
login to that site.
RYAN BOYD: Sure.
I mean the original version of
OpenID basically returned a
opaque identifier back
to the website.
So basically, if you went to
login to TripIt and you wanted
to log in using your Google
account, TripIt would get back
just an identifier that's a
URL or URI and includes a
number that TripIt doesn't
know how to associate.
And even the consumer version
of OpenID today for Gmail
accounts will actually return a
different opaque identifier
for every site that you visit.
That being said, many websites
want more information.
They want to have your name
and they want to have your
e-mail address.
So they include what's called
OpenID attribute exchange
requests as part of their
initial request. And when they
include that, basically you
those additional elements on
the authorization screen saying,
is it OK to pass in
your name and your
e-mail address?
And you can either
allow or deny.
If you had websites that you
really wanted to be entirely
anonymous per se to, then you
wouldn't want to ever approve
a screen that looks like that
and you'd want to encourage
those website developers to not
ask for that information.
We don't currently have a way
to basically say the website
developer asked for it.
You, as a user, can say, no, I
want to login, but I don't
want to pass that information.
We don't currently have that
scenario implemented.
But it's something, if there was
enough requests for, it is
something we could, of
course, look at.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, that's
all great information.
But I don't think that
answers my question.
I'm talking about on the
side of the provider.
Google learning all of the
different sites that I'm
logging in to.
RYAN BOYD: Sorry.
AUDIENCE: No, that's OK.
That's your choice to use
the OpenID provider
that you want to use.
And if you don't like that
provider knowing the different
sites that you're logging in
to, then use a different
provider that you're
OK with that with.
Or use your own provider with
the risk that some websites
might just have that NASCAR
and you can't
use your own provider.
But yeah, I don't have
any fantastic answer
for you on that one.
The way the protocol works is
Google gets to see that
information during
the process.
AUDIENCE: I guess I'm just
wondering if there's going to
be consumer push back or
if we should expect
something like from this.
Thank you.
RYAN BOYD: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Question
about the refresh
tokens around best practices.
Should, as application
developers, we pay attention
to the expiration time and
request a new auth token
before it expires or just wait
to get a fail authorization
and try again?
RYAN BOYD: It would reduce
latency if you expected, if
you looked at it.
Basically, if you did some
background process looking at
when your tokens expire and
knowing that the user is
currently active on your
site and renewing them
automatically.
Because otherwise you're
basically waiting to get--
sorry, a 401 or 403.
I'm sorry, I'm forgetting
which.
But you're basically waiting to
get that return by Google.
And if you do that, then you're
adding an extra request
in the process and the user is
sitting there waiting for you
not only to get the
error, but also to
then refresh the token.
And then get the data.
So it's really up to you.
But if you have an application
that you want to reduce the
latency a lot, I would renew
them in advance.
AUDIENCE: Just a
quick question.
You may not be able to answer
because it might be
outside your area.
But App Engine currently,
I believe, uses
version 1 of OAuth.
Is App Engine going to update
to version 2 of OAuth or are
they sticking with 1?
RYAN BOYD: You're right that I
don't have the answer to that.
I know that there
are libraries.
The API client for Python I
believe has implemented.
Jed is nodding his
head here, yes.
So yes, the API client for
Python distributed by Google,
which you can use on App Engine
does support OAuth 2.
But frankly, OAuth 2 is really
easy to implement, even if you
don't have a library that
supports it I wouldn't be too
scared about trying to
implement OAuth 2.
AUDIENCE: It wasn't so much as
a client, like using App
Engine as a client.
But you can actually use App
Engine as a relying party.
Sorry, as a--
RYAN BOYD: You mean
as a OAuth--
you have an API hosted on App
Engine and you're trying to
authorize users accessing
that API?
So I don't know the
answer to you.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: All right,
thank you.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thanks.
I'm wondering if developers
store the refresh token in the
database and say they have a
Sony moment and the database
gets spilled out to the public,
are those refresh
tokens worth anything by
themselves outside of the app
of the developer who
requested it?
RYAN BOYD: In addition to that
refresh token, they would need
to have that client ID and
client secret in addition.
So I'm trying to think here.
In general, I think that as long
as they weren't able to
get on the client secret,
they would be OK.
Because I'm pretty sure the
client secret is only ever
communicated in server to server
post from the server--
or from the client, from the
web application to Google
using HTTPS.
So it's stored securely
somewhere in their
environment.
I'd still be slightly concerned,
but I think as long
as your storing that data
separately, that would be a
best practice.
AUDIENCE: I don't need
more than just that.
OK, thanks.
RYAN BOYD: Don't get your
database compromised though,
how's that?
AUDIENCE: I think a lot of us
are sort of having tin foil
hat moments with the
APIs on that stuff.
Is there any way for the end
users to know how scrupulous
or not a web application
is when they are
using OAuth or OpenID?
Is there any sort of
certification process or
anything like that for us to
know when we do allow this
token and all of this other
behind the scenes stuff how
securely it's being
implemented?
RYAN BOYD: We don't have
anything that we can provide
you for that.
I would talk to the people
who are implementing.
Talk to the web applications
that you're considering using
and ask them for more
information on their practices.
Look at who they're funded by.
Look at a variety of different
things to determine how much
you trust that company.
But Google does not have any
sort of certification on that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Are the sort of auditing
companies
aware of how this works?
Do they have best practices
for us to follow?
Basically, how much third party
support is there for
really, really solid, secure
use of OAuth and OpenID?
RYAN BOYD: There are certainly
consulting firms that
specialize in this
type of stuff.
There are companies that
actually implement it for you,
and you can just kind
of use their APIs.
Things like Janrain
is an example of
one of those companies.
J-A-N-R-A-I-N.
And they've actually implemented
a lot of the open
source libraries
as well for it.
That My best recommendation
right now would be check out
some of those companies and
certainly do some due
diligence when you're evaluating
applications.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Please, could you elaborate, why
did you use OAuth 1 in the
second business use case?
RYAN BOYD: Sure.
So basically, OAuth 2, the way
we've implemented it thus far,
requires that the user have
an active session in their
browser in order to do
that initial grant.
And the user is granting access
to only their data.
In the case of the business use
case where you want an IT
admin to grant access to
the data for the entire
organization, we just haven't
implemented that yet in an
OAuth 2 style flow.
So it's just a question of time
more than anything else.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey Ryan.
Let's say you have two websites
that are implementing
Google for authentication and
instead of actually using
OAuth to pull data
from Google, you
actually want it to use--
would you be able to support
where they both use the login,
but now they actually can pull
data from each other as
opposed to pulling
data from Google?
RYAN BOYD: So one of them is
pulling data from Google and
then the other one--
AUDIENCE: No, neither of them.
They're just both using Google
for authentication.
RYAN BOYD: You would basically
be establishing some sort of
trust between those
two servers.
And you could use OAuth.
Basically, have those two
services use OAuth for that
trust back and forth.
But it's not something that
Google itself would be
involved in.
You would use authentication,
like use OpenID for
authentication to get access
to the user's identity.
But then to kind of transmit
data between the two servers,
you'd probably use OAuth with
some sort of trust between
those two servers.
AUDIENCE: Right.
So you have to implement
your own OAuth?
RYAN BOYD: Yeah.
I mean you could use other
protocols, but that would be
one way to do it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Facebook and LinkedIn have
implemented OAuth 2 in the
user agent flow, which doesn't
involve secrets at all.
This is very useful for
developers who want to just do
client side authentication.
Does Google support that?
I see OAuth 2.0 with the last
step in the dance as about
exchanging that access
token for using code.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, we do
support entirely
user agent based flow.
I didn't really get into the
details in the presentation.
We do support entirely user
agent based dance, where you
could do it purely
from JavaScript.
There may still be
a secret, but the
secret is known to everyone.
So you just need to
be aware of that.
AUDIENCE: That kind
of sucks, right?
RYAN BOYD: I'm not sure
if our current flow--
I know that some of the folks
like LinkedIn have implemented
it where the user actually has
to have a current active
session in order to refresh
their access token.
Whereas, the implementation that
I showed the user doesn't
have an active session.
But I'm not sure what our
support is for that yet.
I can certainly talk with you
afterwards and get more info.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
I'll reach out to you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
What's the relationship between
what you've talked
about today and Open Social?
RYAN BOYD: Sorry, I
have 30 seconds.
AUDIENCE: I'll talk
to you afterwards.
RYAN BOYD: Yes, let's
chat afterwards.
Thank you very much, everyone.
Thank you.